warren buffett one of the richest people
in the world the oracle of omaha he's
previously said that bitcoin is rat
poison well warren buffett now has been
dumping his legacy financial stocks like
visa and mastercard and instead he's now
putting billions of dollars into a
company called new bank this is
fascinating because warren buffett is
investing billions of dollars in a
company that is friendly to bitcoin
we'll get to that in one second but the
most important part is that warren
buffett previously called bitcoin rat
poison and his partner charlie munger
said that it was like trading dead
harvested baby brains i don't know what
that means but it sounds bad now warren
buffett charlie munger and berkshire
hathaway they've got a lot of money and
they previously have had that money
invested in banks and legacy financial
firms but they've been selling a lot of
that stock they recently sold 1.3
billion dollars of mastercard they sold
1.8 billion dollars of visa in june of
last year they invested 500 million
dollars in new bank's parent company in
december they invested another 250
million dollars and they recently just
invested one billion dollars in
newbank's parent company and so
ultimately who is newbank what do they
do where do they come from well here's
some details they were founded in 2013
they're a digital bank based in brazil
they have about 40 million customers and
when we say that they're bitcoin
friendly there's a little bit of nuance
here that's important to call out they
don't actually offer crypto trading on
their platform and their ability for
customers to buy and sell bitcoin or
other cryptocurrencies but they have an
investment unit called new invest which
allows users to invest in crypto etfs
including a bitcoin etf that previously
has been approved and listed and so
ultimately new bank they like bitcoin
they like crypto they've got the etf
structures and they're bringing them to
customers around the world and warren
buffett keeps piling in cash new bank
now is a publicly listed company it went
public at a 41 billion valuation this is
a big boy company and they understand
bitcoin is good for business warren
buffett may say that bitcoin is rat
poison charlie munger may call dead baby
brains don't listen to what they say
watch what they do they're continuing to
shovel money into a company that is a
digital bank that's bitcoin friendly
ultimately warren buffett charlie munger
berkshire hathaway and the legion of
value investors they have they're all
going to capitulate eventually they're
all going to buy bitcoin they're going
to continue to fund the infrastructure
that helps this industry grow don't
listen to what they say watch what they
do warren buffett's got indirect
exposure to bitcoin and eventually all
of his friends will too hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time